الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى في كتابه الكريم
وجاءت
سكره الموت بالحق
ذلك ما كنت منه تحيد
الله سبحانه وتعالى
tell সুحانه وى
‏and
so trouing to us
is
going to be.
We don't know how it is going to be.
We don't know where it is going to be.
‏But that is all knowledge that we do
not need truly.
If anything, the answers to those
question would imped our journey to if
we were to have them.
A trouing
of our existence is our morality.
الله سبحانه وتعالى
are
approaching
with breath we take with beat of our
heart
and our death
‏We don't know when we die.
We don't know how. And we don't know
where.
‏And some of us don't even know why.
And this is something that trouy
from Allah.
‏anwers to these question
and if anything if we had thew to these
question
that knowledge would do us more harm
than good
when we think of our death i mean truly
think of our death
not the way that pop culture
speaks and refers to death like ‏J not
de
well you got die the person says as
theyise the poison to their
not me by
tells
inران
‏trting with our without distractions
and imagining that one day
could be today could be in 5 minutes,
could be in 50 years. ‏We don't know.
And honestly what's ironic about that it
is just as likely to be 5 minutes from
now as it is 50 years from now. It's
just as likely.
‏Not one of us here is able to guarantee
that he has another 10 breaths left in
his lifan
or breaths.
One of us here can guarantee that his
heart or her heart will beat another
time after this.
That's the irony of death.
‏And this either empowers us or it
cripples us.
Allah subhanahu waalainds us of death
and he refers to it as
what is
Allah gives us the imagery of the
drunken state
of being a death doorstep.
‏Because when a person is about to die
and the usion collapses
and the here's reality rushes in the
true colors of that person manifest
and come to the surface and rise to the
surface just a person who is
unimped
‏ingarations
when they drink enough
they become very truthful
people when they drink alcohol when they
reach a state of intoxication
to where they are feeling good they
feeling they just on cloud
and they get thatquid courage aser to
they then start to
‏and
الله سبحانه وتالى
سكره الموت
ذلك ما كنت منه تحيد
ايش يعني تحيد؟ يعني هارب منه تحيد
شارد وهارب يمين وشمال
تريد ان تنجو من الموت ذلك ما كنت منه
تحيد
اينما تكونوا يدرككم الموت ولو كنتم في
بروج مشيده يقول الله
ويقول سبحانه وتعالى
ولن يؤخر الله نفسا اذا جاء اجلها حتى
الانبياء والرسل
اذا جاءت اجالهم فان الله لن يؤخر هذا
الشيء لماذا؟ لان الله تعالى خلق هذا
الخلق باتقان
الذي احسن كل شيء خلقه خلقه
احسن اي ادقن كل شيء
وخلق السماوات والارض وما بينهما
بالحق واجل مسمى
سمى هذا الاجل حتى البعوضه
سمى اجلها قبل ان يخلقها سبحانه وتعالى
‏Everyone of us has a date, a time, a
place that we will die. And no one can
save us from this moment.
‏It's a moment of truth.
It's the moment that our enti life has
been working up
our prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
usice
that if we were to make our decisions in
life based on this advice we would
rarely fall short.
اكثروا ذكر
اللذات
often
constantly on the droyer of pleasures
meaning death it destroys pleasures.
‏It makes
food not t as good
and makes our feelings of eupia
when we're getting just what we want,
just how we want, just when we want a
little bit more dull
because we remember that no matter how
vivid something is, no matter how good
it feels, no matter how vivid the
euphoria
‏Every single one of us has a day and
time of death.
Youve seen a people you have seen a dead
peopleentually.
‏Now it doesn't mean that we live a life
of some kind of twisted
death
where we actively seek our death. No,
but death
is
the true litmus test of whether you are
upon truth or falsehood in your life.
‏any
you on any
in your life
you look through the lens of
death
with this thing that I'm doing here is
my death going to enhance this thing or
is it going to stunt it and ruin it
and if
‏by
not
anything
out the
un can make peace with death and death
into the framewor of why we live it is
not the truth it
‏Because death we're t in this western
culture since we are kids we t that is
unnatural
death
only happens when someone makes a
mistake somewhere
that someh we control death
that death only happens if there's
someone to blame for it.
‏That is not at all what death is. As a
matter of fact, death could be the most
natural thing in the world.
Life is the true anomaly. Death is the
default state of everything.
‏Life is an anom where does it come from
why life strugle and
against why
if I today
years from now what is the differ in the
grand schem of thingsutely
nothing
and so one the greatestw
to
‏B te us de
looked as anything except for the end of
many stages that the human being goes
through.
‏go primary stages
in
advancement in his journey to
and is a necessary step
doesn't have to be a bad thing it
doesn't have to be that someone is
responsible and a mistake was made when
death comes to visit
is
‏natural thing in the world. What is
unnatural is to act it doesn't
exist to act it only happens to
other people it only happens to people
in the news. Death doesn't happen to us
it happ to everyone else not us.
‏If you go to the cemetery
and you look at those tombstones and you
spend some time there and you put
yourone away and you don't speak and you
don't talk and you live in that moment,
you're going to observe a pattern there
and that is that there is no age for
death.
‏are infants that die the moment they
born are people die over years and
everything
there
to us as to when a person
you could go and get a checkup and
everything is tip top and walk out of
the doctor's office get hit by a cookie
truck and off to the cemetery you go
and then we try to make sense.
الله سبحانه وتالى
you can you needle
pres الله
سبحانه وتعالى
اولم يتفكروا
ما خلق الله السماوات والارض وما بينهما
الا بالحق
واجل مسمى
ليس فقط معلوم عند الله بل سماه وكتبه في
اللوح المحفوظ ولن يؤخر الله نفسا اذا جاء
اجلها
اللهcept
[Silence]
already date of expiration
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏to
all of us got together andaborated to
stop aing man froming we would not be
able to
we will onlyble one another which has
already written for us
what do we do
what we do how
you're not supposed to get away from
death
‏O purose
timer
and
go
in to
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
trees
mat
on he took when
صلى الله عليه وسلم
and would another
go
that is how to dr
and
w up
around himed
عليه الصلاه والسلام فشق ذلك على صحابته
فقالوا يا رسول الله افلا اذنتنا يعني
اذنت لنا واخبرتنا
فنجعل لك وطاء نسوي لك فرش تنام عليها
ترتاح انت رسول
‏said
they were disted when they saw this
matinting
on side they said messenger of Allah if
you tell us we and you would us will
make you mat you can somethingable
and said
ولدنيا
انما انا كراكب استظل تحت شجره
ثم راح وتركها
انظروا الى هذا التصوير العظيم
قبل ظل هذه الشجره في صحراء متراميه
الاطراف تصوروا معي
شجره
في وسط هذه الصحراء
قبل هذه الشجره قبل ان يخلق الانسان
وما بعد هذه الشجره الاخره
وظل هذه الشجره
الى جانب هذه الصحراء
حياتنا في هذه الدنيا
بس نقطه
غيض من فيض كما يقولون نقطه من بحر
الله
make
[Silence]
‏with a desert that you can see no end
to it
and a tree right there in the midle a
little tiny spe in the grand scheme of
things with a small diameter of shade.
What came before that tree is you and I
before we were born.
‏And what comes after that tree is what
you and I are headed to once we check
out and die.
‏Once the most beloved people to us, the
ones who say, "I love you the most, once
they take you and take me and put you in
a hole in the ground and go home,
once that happens, you and I will head
to the second part after that tree and
all of our lives on this
is that little shade under the tree,
that 10 or 15 minuter sit
‏breath before
that is our life on this you have few
minut here you make you go that's
all the anger all the love all the
people are killing each other a father
will kill his own son a mother her own
daughter brothers will kill each other
over this dunia it's just that little
speck of shade in the midst
‏that is
no matter how much and they give it no
matter how many ne on that's all
is
that's all it is and you may not believe
this now or we may have a hard time
swallowing this now but I tell you what
the interesting thing ‏about
is no matter how good or bad a person is
the most righteous of men and the most
wicked of devil when they die they will
be hit with overwhelming feeling common
to everyone. They will all arrive at the
same haunting realization at that moment
of death.
‏of
that moment of you and I will see this
for what it is.
‏anger that I had, all those grudges
that I h all those words I got my blood
pressure all worked up for that's all it
was a spe
on the windshield of eternity that is
our life here now that can either be the
best news youve ever heard or the worst
news youve ever heard
but your death doesn't have to be a bad
day
your death
‏your can be a celebration
you can make it that right now right now
no matter what happen in the you can
turn your intof
ولكم ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه
انه هو الغفور الرحيم.
الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
تاكيدا بعد تاكيد لبيان مقام التوحيد
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه
وخليله وامينه على وحيه
الداعي الى رضوانه
صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما
باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا
وكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وتوفانا مع الابرار ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا
على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه انك لا
تخلف الميعاد ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه
وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا
عذاب النار وقنا عذاب النار اللهم اجعلنا
ادله على المؤمنين اعزه على الكافرين
نقاتل ونجاهد في سبيلك حتى ياتينا اليقين
اللهم ربنا انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل
الشرك والمشركين
وافطح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
اللهم دمره تدميرا اللهم اللهم زلزل
اركانه وصدع بنيانه واقتل اجناده اللهم
اقذف في قلوب اصحابه الهلع والفزع والرعب
يا رب العالمين اللهم ربنا اننا نسالك فعل
الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب المساكين وان
تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت
بعبادك فتنه
فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين فاقبضنا اليك
غير مفتونين فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم اجعل خير ايامنا يوم نلقاك فيه
اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء ومنازل
الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء والنصر على
الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء هذا المن والعطاء
اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا
[Arabic recitation]
out
‏you
here you might do itly do not a sure
that the ahad of you isely full your
shoulders and your feet and aners and
feet and anbors
الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين
اذا زلزلت الارض زلزالها
واخرجت الارض اثقالها
وقال الانسان
ما لها
يومئذ
تحدث اخبارها بان ربك اوحى لها
يصدر الناس اشتاتا ليروا اعمالهم
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا
يره
ومن يعمل مثقال ذره
شرا
يره
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن
الهاكم التكاثر
حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترن
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن النعيم
الله
[Silence]
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
كده
[Silence]
الله اكبر
ورحمه ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر الله
السلام عليكم سز
বান্ভؤم
[Silence]
اشفه شفاء تاما لا يغادر سقما اللهم اشفه
شفاء تاما لا يغادر سقما اللهم اجل اجعل
هذه العقبه اجعلها اللهم رحمه له وتكفيرا
لذنبه ورفعه في درجاته اللهم اشفه وتب
عليه اللهم افرغ عليه وعلى اهله الصبر
والسلوى اللهم انسهم بانسك لا انس الا
انسك اللهم امين وصل اللهم
مك الله
ان
ইলাম ইনশল্লাহ পজি অক্সালামু
[Arabic recitation]
عليكم السلام الحمد لله السلام عليكم